en fait quoi faire maxime j'ai donné une
petite combine en plus des magiciens et
depuis plusieurs mois tu essaies de là
c'est dur donc je vais te montrer
comment faire d'accor le plaisir on va
en faire un tout avec 2 42 2 13 passes
on peut bien avoir à la caméra je
l'utilisais j'ai pas de retour votre
nokia fait cenal s'inquiéter à ce que tu
prends de la marque heures c'est le
temps plein je vais faire une grosse
signature qualité mais tu veux en gros
si nature s'il te plait ça fait très
bien il n'est bien souvent ce qu'on va
faire on va le laisser sécher un tout
petit peu on va prendre deux trèfles va
plier en deux et en quatre je vais
simplement te demander de mettre ses
entretiens dans celle qu'a pété sexy
j'ai fait la même chose moi le cadre de
coeur voilà qu'on montre ici
pareil je prendre la carte que je vais
signer parfait on va laisser sécher non
mais ça de côté et je vais faire la même
chose que toi quelle est la terre
tondeuse en carton-pâte yacine et la
note laissée lors de manches qu'il faut
faire vraiment de demain encore une fois
on vaccine gagnant nettement dans le
vert droit
[Musique]
à la mi août la france fait
attention voilà au la soul assez chaud
[Musique]
tu fais ça fonctionne pas non non je
peux prendre la carte doucement
annonçait le nom de tous ceux qui s'est
traduite au côté de tous côtés c'était
donc au tour du double dames renard
prime en direct et tu as retourne c'est
un shérif carter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comme je me sens
ce jour là mathieu avait sorti une bonne
vanne à miss france 2010 8
maeva cook avait une soeur jumelle anisé
qui est mannequin
wima dieu bénisse la famille et mon
frère sur jumelles alizée qui est
mannequin
wima dieu bénisse la famille après elle
pas un frère
[Applaudissements]
il est tellement un marchand de bonheur
celui là il est taillé peur il y en a
trop et officiels officiel tu m'en fiche
un peu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis fait tant parce que je sais que
tu esthéticienne no way et pilar maillot
[Musique]
je ne dis pas ça parce que c'est mon ami
mais mention particulière à benjamin
castaldi qui est un très très grand
animateur
[Applaudissements]
je voulais te dire autre chose sans
refaire la même chose avec jean michel
mr et à date
ah ouais enfin michel ailleurs c'est un
truc en plus non non c'est vrai c'est
vrai c'est coup dur pour faire la même
chose en fait tu sûr qu'un délire ya un
truc très bien tu parais tu vas s'il te
plaît arrêtez de signer la tarte
voilà pour fait exactement la même chose
à l ocha très bien donc ce qu'on va
faire pareil on va prendre date pour
l'appuyer en 2004 dont la nôtre tu es
dans ta carte dessinée est pareil je te
demander de prendre la carte non classé
voilà je signe ici pour la cour
d'assises est déjà entré dans pareil
voilà vous faites vous retournez voilà
non comme ça face à face ce que je veux
faire
tu te ramasses cap la date parfait est
pareil
[Applaudissements]
postale et beaucoup parlé de la
politesse à tous ces incompétents c'est
bien sûr choisir que la vérité est
ensuite
je suis content
je
gillis mans
on n'est pas du tout
ça me
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais regarde la carte était sinueuse is
it imagine stasi l'on retourne
franchement personne de toit a cédé
général
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]